Now people that are journalists
and writers often like stimulants,
they often like Adderall. Adderall
is a big issue for, uh, for,
for journalists. How much experience do
you have with Adderall? I'm at East it,
it's supposed to be amazing.
I've never tried to use it precisely
because I know I would love it, right.
Like I would,
I,
I've got a young relative
whose prescribed it and um,
during the times when I've
been telling you he's a, yeah,
he's often tried to know spike me but
like to join him and this is for you,
I'd role opens up a whole other thing.
Right.
Which is this what you're talking about
again, which is I'm not against people,
obviously not against people using
drugs in order to enhance their lives.
And I have,
before I came here,
I drank enough caffeine to kill a
whole fucking field of cows. Right.
I assume viewers can probably tell I'm,
I personally limit my
stimulant use because um,
because I know I can teach. Yeah.
And I can tell that I could easily,
a bit like we had to be the
modafinil when I start using that.
We definitely got that sense. I just
used it everyday for three months. Right.
Which was ludicrous thing to do.
But um,
I think in terms of stimulants, there's
a whole debate that needs to be had. Now,
I'm going to write about this
at some point, but one in 10,
13 year old boys in this country
is being given a stimulant drug,
right? In any given year, right?
For add or Adhd or, I mean,
that is horrifying. It's crazy, right?
30% of children in foster
care in the United States,
I've been given at least
one psychiatric drug.
These are not children in
the main who are, you know,
have some biological insanity.
These are kids who've been fucking
abused and treated abysmally.
And what do we do? We drug them
to shut them up, right? Well,
it's also children have a lot of energy
and it's not easy to control them.
And so they decide that these children
have something wrong with them.
Do you know, I went to this Amish village
Veloce connections, but when things,
it's really interesting,
there are these people who argued that
needs to be more research on this.
But Amish children don't get Adhd,
right?
And this is big debate what's going
on there. And so there's one argument,
which is obviously not exposed
to digital media, which may, uh,
and there's some evidence of just
speaking to professor Steven Lee here,
but people were getting a lot loads of
ADHD when I was in school and they're,
exactly, exactly. So that's just
because I spoke to a guy at Ucla,
professor Stephen Nation,
there's some effect to digital media,
but it's not massive. Right? Right. Um,
I think what's happening from the
very small amount of research you,
you're talking to the Amish
is, you know, I'd say to them,
do you have kids who don't want
to sit still? And they go, yeah,
we'll let and golf and go fishing.
Right?
The Amish don't want to make you sit
still for eight hours a day. Right.
There's nothing in their society
that I'm not an idealized image.
She has problems with getting a child
to sit still for eight hours a day,
just like trying to get a puppy to
sit still for eight hours a day.
And that's exactly the right analogy.
What we do to our children.
We tried to deaden them and discipline
them to cope and thrive in a dead end and
disciplines in inverted commerce economy.